as Brett Kavanaugh takes his seat on the
Supreme Court the left copes inmature
considered fashion or not I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show oh
[Music]
man we have a lot going on today we're
gonna tell all the news in just a second
first I want to let you know that
tonight is round two my next stop in my
yaf tour it takes me to University of
Buffalo so if you are anywhere near or
around the Buffalo area starting at 7:30
p.m. Eastern 4:30 p.m. Pacific you can
actually watch me dismantle the left
both in person and online at EF dot org
slash live that's yah org slash live
make sure to bring your tumblers to
collect leftist tears because there's a
tidal wave over the weekend and I know
that we have to somehow contain those
leftist here somewhere so the tumblers
will come in handy also also before we
get into the news I want to remind you
that you don't actually have to go to
the post office the post office is great
there's a lot of great stuff there but
why do you want to get in the car and
spend the time going down to the post
office when you can just sit at your
desk and instead get all the great
services of the post office right there
with stamps calm you can get all the
amazing services of the post office
directly from your desk 24/7 when it is
convenient for you buy in print official
US postage for any letter and any
package using your own computer and
printer mail carrier picks it up you
click print mail you're done we've used
stamps calm at the office daily wire for
quite a while we save ourselves time and
money that way plus we have a digital
scale allows us to calculate exact post
egde well you can do that too because
right now using promo code Shapiro you
get up to 55 bucks of free postage a
digital scale and a four week trial when
you go to stamps calm before you do
anything else you click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and you type in at Shapiro that
stamps.com promo code Shapiro again you
get that special deal post office has a
lot of great stuff but there's no reason
for you to have to go there instead you
can just do it directly from your desk
go to stamps.com use that promo code
Shapiro and again got fifty five bucks
of free postage a digital scale on the
four week trial when you do stamps comm
use promo code Shapiro okay so over the
weekend Democrats really handled the
Brett Kavanaugh vote I think with great
aplomb dignity poise folks on the Left
really you know they they really I think
showed tremendous maturity when they
realized that Brett Kavanaugh is
actually gonna be on the Supreme Court
for those who missed it Brett Kavanaugh
was confirmed on Saturday by a fifty to
forty eight vote
it was only 52 48 not 51 to 49 because
Mike Danes who's the senator from North
Dakota had to go home for his his
daughter's wedding and to Lisa Murkowski
abstained instead of voting against
against Kavanagh so became a fifty to
forty eight vote and Democrats responded
in their typically moderated and I think
modulated fashion was really it was
really good to watch it was good to see
the country come together after such a
rough time because Democrats did I
thought just a great job I mean like
here was is what happened at the Supreme
Court immediately as Cavanaugh was being
confirmed inside for those who can't
actually see this the other people who
are legitimately standing there beating
on the 13-ton bronze doors of the
Supreme Court my favorite is this lady
who's trying to pry the door open she
like like Frodo trying to get into the
mines of moria without the actual
passcode she's just there trying to pry
open the doors with her bare hands
though the doors are gonna part before
her it's pretty pretty astonishing stuff
obviously people really reacting well to
all of this we have an anti Cavanaugh
protester he started threatening people
as well so that was pretty solid and
like to this this is good I don't know
if this guy was arrested or what but
things obviously have cooled down in the
country
I'm sure this fellow is an expert in the
intricacies of Supreme Court
jurisprudence based simply on the
language that he's using with regard to
his political enemies I'm sure that he
knows the entire line of cases
stretching prior to Griswold on the
rights of privacy and he's just upset
and how that line of cases could be
curbed by the presence of Brett
Kavanaugh on supreme court probably
that's what's going on but I don't want
to make it sound like it's just you know
members of an angry mob or involved in
being an angry mob I mean they are but
it's more than that right it's it's some
of the elites in our society first of
all I'll be remissed here if I didn't
know that Cory Gardner says that his
wife has now received gruesome
heading video after his pro Cavanagh
vote and he's not the only one who's
receiving those sorts of threats those
threats actually are becoming quite
common with regard to Republican members
of Congress I've heard from a few of
them who have said that this sort of
thing is becoming sort of the norm but
as I say this isn't just that the people
that sort of the the popular level of
the Democratic Party this isn't just
leftist grassroots folks who are very
very upset we're talking about high
ranking Democratic Party people who have
completely lost their mind
I mean legitimately and completely lost
their mind over Brett Kavanaugh joining
the Supreme Court in much the way
they've lost their mind over Donald
Trump being elected in the first place
so take for example this amazing hero
knows amazing Hirono is a senator from
Hawaii and she specifically asked
whether she believes that people should
be confronted Republicans should be
confronted at restaurants and in their
daily lives watch as she Bob's and
weaves to avoid answering the question
as to whether people should be harassed
in their daily lives through the road on
Kavanagh I think that it just means that
there are a lot of people who are very
very much motivated but what is going on
because what did what happened with
judge Kavanagh is from the very
beginning this was not a fair process so
that's going on you know what
restaurants talk well this is what
happens you know they because when you
look at white supremacist and all that
this is what's it coming forth in our
country there's a tremendous divisive
Ness
country but this is the kind of activism
that occurs and people make their own
decisions oh people make their own
decisions
right but we're asking about your
opinion on the decisions they're making
see like we're asking whether you think
it's okay to yell at Ted Cruz's wife in
a restaurant or yell at Sarah Huckabee
Sanders or try and harass senators you
think well you know people have their
opinions yeah people have their opinions
my opinion is the mazie Hirono is a
completely immoral person based on these
statements or at least she's making
completely immoral statements as pretty
astonishing stuff it's not just mazie
Hirono of course you have the members of
Hollywood and and members of the comic
community who are joining in so here is
a writer for Stephen Colbert Stephen
Colbert as we all know the finest
comedian among us and in just just a
hysterical example of heartbreaking
genius he has a writer named Arielle
Dumas or dumbass I hope that I think
that it's probably properly pronounced
the latter
what she wrote whatever happens I'm just
glad we ruined Brett Kavanaugh his life
yeah I have a feeling that's how a lot
of folks on the Left actually feel these
days so points for honesty and then you
have these these comedians who decided
they're gonna follow around Brian
Kilmeade so Brian is legitimately one of
the nicest people in the media business
that has nothing to do with politics
Brian is just a genuinely nice human
being he's walking to the subway I
believe from Fox News home and comics
started following him on the subway and
then harassing him on the subway asking
people on the subway to harass him as
well and here's what that sounded like
if you have anything you want Donald
Trump to say or do tell this guy because
he's the only person in America at the
Donald Trump listens to I'll literally
give you $10 if yes Trump to resign
about look in the camera Newsday Donald
president it's time to resign I'll raise
it to 15 15 15 $15.50 a napkin 550 ax
mango
the only person that could stop this
mess please I'm begging you I'm begging
you so much comedian so much journalism
these folks on the on the Left they they
really they're really holding it
together nicely I think I think they're
they're really holding it together in a
pretty significant way kirsten
gillibrand by the way if you think that
the extremists in the Democratic base
are in no way related to the the folks
at the top of the Democratic Party all
you have to do is is watch the
relationship between the two Linda
Sarsour who's legitimately a pro
terrorist operative I mean she actually
has stood up for terrorists before she's
radically anti-semitic she of course is
one of the heads of the women's March
she introduced Christian Gillibrand at
one of the this at this latest rally
outside the Supreme Court so she here's
here's an actual terrorist supporter
introducing a sitting senator of the
United States an event and no one on the
Left batting an eye works for us on the
inside someone who understands that she
works for the people of this country
who's been speaking up against sexual
assault and sexual violence before there
was a breakout na please give it up to
the senator from the greatest state in
the United States of America my state
New York senator Kirsten Gillibrand
how delightful what a delight and
there's Kirsten Gillibrand you know real
feminist
standing up there with Amy Schumer as a
woman who talked about the great paid
maternity leave in Saudi Arabia
introduces her the good stuff there from
the Democratic Party President Trump is
correct that the Democrats have indeed
turned into an angry mob and you can see
how much an angry mob they've turned
into when we get to what policies they
are proposing because it's pretty
astonishing but here's President Trump
hitting the nail on the head as I've
said before the president is a hammer
sometimes he hits a nail sometimes he
hits a baby well yesterday he hit a nail
and it was satisfying because he said
what is correct here the the only thing
Democrats had to do honestly when Trump
was elected all Democrats had to do was
not be crazy that's all they had to do
they have failed dramatically in that
task of not being crazy instead they've
decided to go full-blown crazy here as
president from pointing that out
in their quest for power the radical
Democrats have turned into an angry mob
you saw that today with the screaming
and the shouting not from the 200 people
or less that weren't you know what those
people they couldn't fit in the front
row look what we have here today
okay Trump is exactly right about all
this now what are the left what are the
folks on the Left wanted to about this
well they want to do two things one they
want to come up with systemic ways to
change the system and two they want to
try it out a war on women narrative the
war on women narrative is their great
hope that they can start a war of the
sexes they tried this in 2016 they said
that there was a war on women and
Hillary Clinton was a representative of
women in this fight they are hoping that
because President Trump is alienating to
a lot of particularly suburban women
that they can glom on to that and then
they can combine that with enthusiasm
for the metes you movement and use that
to Club Republicans into submission on a
political level we'll get to the war on
women narrative in a second but first
what they want to do is they want to
radically change the system of American
government their full-blown members of
the media I'm talking about Washington
Post reporters today who are shocked
shocked to discover that the Senate of
the United States is not represented by
population they're shocked to discover
that in fact each state has two senators
and then they realize that wait Montana
has fewer people than New York which
means the Senate isn't representative Oh
God there literally realizing this like
right now it's it hey I don't know where
they been for out of the past 300 years
in this country but yeah I mean that
this is actually a case that they are
making right now we'll get to all of
that in just one second first let's talk
about the software that your company is
using when's the last time you updated
the software company uses probably not
recently because you figure it's more of
a hassle to try and figure out what
software to use and then install it than
it is to just plot along using this old
software except you're losing time and
you're losing money which is why you
ought to talk to the folks over at
software advice when it comes to picking
the right software for your business
software advice has done all the
research for you their team of Advisors
can point you in the right directions
you can start working more effectively
right away and it is absolutely free
just go to software advice.com slash pen
you answer a few short questions about
your business you'll be connected with
an advisor to discuss the best software
options for your needs talking to an
advisor can take just 10 minutes or less
whether you're a medical professional or
a construction manager or an HR pro
software advice will save you time and
help you make a more informed decision
so if you're not entrepreneur you work
solo software advice is a great way to
get an expert opinion even without the
resources of a big company go check them
out right now go to software advice.com
slash Ben to get started software advice
calm /ban know we here at the daily wire
are very up on our technology one of the
reasons why we have a successful company
but you need to be as well I'm sorry you
using that old 1997 Microsoft Word
format ain't gonna work anymore you
can't use you know that you can't use
the old the old spreadsheets that you
were using 20 years ago go to software
advice.com slash man connect with an
advisor for free software advice.com
slash Ben go check them out right now ok
so the media have discovered a few
things that they are upset about
so after 2016 they discovered they
didn't like the electoral college very
much because Hillary lost and now
they've discovered that there is such a
thing called the United States Senate
and that the United States Senate
Believe It or Not actually represents a
different population than the House of
Representatives now originally the
Constitution said that the Senate was
not even to be selected by popular vote
within the states originally the state
legislature selected their own senators
which was the correct move that's the
way it should have worked because that
meant that there was even another layer
between the population and the Senate
see the founders were actually quite
worried about mob rule they were quite
worried
the idea of peer democracy because they
figured that demagoguery could win over
broad swaths of the population and that
would enable all sorts of bad things to
happen to minorities inside the United
States is what they're worried about and
so they set up a system of checks and
balances to provide for the rights of
states while ensuring that if there was
overwhelming support for a measure that
all of that would be able to happen
anyway but Aaron Blake over at the
Washington Post in shocking news
breaking news he's the senior political
reporter at The Washington Post this is
breaking news guys hot off the wires
quote people are suddenly deciding the
population disparities rendered the
Senate undemocratic upon ratification
Virginia had 12 times as many people as
Delaware disparities are bigger now but
they very much existed when our founders
decided on the system so Aaron Blake is
Aaron Blake is is obviously you know
actually saying the truth here but
they're a bunch of people in the media
who have been suddenly calling on folks
to get rid of the Senate I'm not kidding
there's a I'm looking for all the tweets
right now but basically they're making
the case that the Senate needs to go
away or alternatively they're making the
case instead that the that the Supreme
Court ought to be packed so my favorite
is Democrats suggesting that Republicans
undemocratically got Brett Kavanaugh
through the Senate when Republicans had
the votes in the Senate somehow that's
undemocratic and now they're saying
there's solution to the undemocratic
nature of the movement of Brett
Kavanaugh to the supreme court requires
them to add more justices to the Supreme
Court in violation of the Constitution
this is from the New York Times today
the bitter partisan fury that engulfed
justice Brett Kavanaugh Supreme Court
confirmation was the fiercest battle in
a political war over the judiciary that
has been steadily intensifying since the
Senate rejected judge Robert Bork in
1987 but an even greater conflagration
may be coming this confirmation vote
will not necessarily be the last word on
Brett Kavanaugh serving a lifetime
appointment on the Supreme Court said
Brian Fallon executive director of
liberal group demand justice and the top
spokesman for Hillary's 2016 campaign so
what exactly are they talking about some
have gone as far as proposing if
Democrats were to retake control of
Congress and the White House in 2020 or
after expanding the number of justices
on the court to pack it with liberals or
trying to impeach remove and replace
Brett Kavanaugh so
it's so good news the Democrats are
taking this all extraordinarily well
they just want to change the system of
government completely they want to get
rid of the Senate and they also want to
and they also want to increase the
number of justices on the Supreme Court
because they couldn't win an election so
well done to Democrats that that's
that's kind of tactic number one then
there is tactic number two and tactic
number two is okay we'll leave the
institutions of government in place but
what we are going to focus on innately
and inordinately is the supposed the
supposed war on women so this is one of
the great lies that's being perpetrated
it's being perpetrated by folks like
Valerie Jarrett so Valerie Jarrett you
will remember was the top adviser to
President Obama and she tweeted this out
I think it sums up well the argument
being made by folks on the Left quote to
all of the survivors of sexual assault
and women who wonder if they will be
believed if they are attacked no there's
a growing powerful movement of support
that will always have your back we
believe you we will stand with you we
will defend you change is coming so the
idea here is that if you support a Brett
Kavanaugh you are ignoring women who
make allegations of sexual assault this
is so transparent and it's really quite
vicious and disgusting I again opposed
Roy Moore for the Senate in Alabama as a
Republican because there is verifiable
evidence that he had done bad things
with young girls when he was a younger
man I did not vote for President Trump
in large measure because of his
treatment of women there are lots of
people who are not happy with sexual
assault allegations not on the left on
the left they're okay as long as it's
Ted Kennedy or Bill Clinton but there
are a lot of people who actually get
kind of upset about these allegations
but Brett Cavanaugh's case did not have
the required verification or
corroboration kristinb lazy's for his
account sort of fell apart Susan Collins
the senator from Maine who came out in
favor of Brett Cavanaugh she was
basically the deciding vote she's been
ripped apart for what she had to say on
CNN but there's nothing innately wrong
with what she said on CNN
here is her explaining that while she
believes something happened to Christine
Blasi Ford she just doesn't believe that
according to the preponderance of the
evidence that Brett Kavanaugh was that
it was the guy who did it I do not
believe that Brett Kavanaugh was her
assailant so I do believe that she was
assaulted I don't know by whom and I'm
not certain when but I do not believe
that he was CEO so people okay and that
prompted mazie Hirono to come and say
how could susan collins doubt
how could susan collins doubt well it's
really funny because i remember that
like a week ago literally a week ago
there's a woman named Julie sweat Nick
brought forward by Michael avenatti and
she claimed that Brett Kavanaugh had
gang-raped her or that he was involved
in gang rapes you never hear her name
anymore from the Democrats why don't
they believe all women don't they
believe that all women ought to be
believed regardless of whether there is
any sort of verifiable or corroborate of
evidence but Julie sweat next were to
disappear boom she was gone so now it's
not believe all women it's believed the
women who we want to believe because
they're slightly more credible and then
Republicans say okay well we agree that
Ford was slightly more credible than
sweat neck but we don't believe that
she's totally credible either or at
least her story isn't corroborated and
then people like no no no that means you
don't you're not believing all women
right but you don't believe all women
you don't believe Juanita Broderick you
don't believe Kathleen Willey you don't
believe Paula Jones you don't believe
the waitresses we're sandwiched by Ted
Kennedy and Chris Dodd back in the
nineteen eighties you don't believe any
of that stuff it's just it's maddening
but here's mazie Hirono saying how could
susan collins even have a doubt how
could you even have it because this is a
free country where we do not condemn
people without due process of law and we
certainly don't condemn people's lives
to the ash heap of history simply
without any corroborate of evidence
whatsoever well to say that she thinks
that dr. Ford thinks that she was
assaulted what is that is she mistaken
there was cooperation because she had
talked about this assault to her husband
two others before Brett Kavanaugh was
ever nominated to the Supreme Court she
took a lie-detector test Corporation was
there okay so mazie Hirono just again
this is the line so the line is that we
may have lost the battle with regarding
Brett Kavanaugh but winning the cultural
war the cultural war is going to be that
men versus women and that women always
must be believed and that men who do not
buy in or women who don't buy in are
just lackeys of the system this is the
argument be made so Alyssa Milano was on
Meet the Press which is just because of
her expertise in men so Alyssa Milano
showed up on Meet the Press after
showing up at the hearing because of
Dianne Feinstein who's a very
serious senator we know Alyssa Milano on
Meet the Press and she explained were
winning the cultural battle I think a
lot has changed but I also think a lot
hasn't changed and yesterday we we may
have lost a political battle but I do
think we are winning the cultural battle
and often I don't fight for the win
I'm fighting so that generations don't
have to deal with the abuses of power
that we've had to deal with okay so this
is this is what Democrats are hoping and
they are hoping in the most wild
possible way in a second I'm going to
give you the article of the day and this
one truly is astonishing because it's
just incredible but first let's talk
let's talk about your sleep quality so
full and branch can make your sleep
quality better ok we're not going to
agree on everything in fact you may not
agree on anything but we can all agree
we can use a better sleep so that's why
you ought to have some better sheets the
reality is you don't think about your
sheets you just went down to the local
store and you picked up whatever sheets
were there and you figured oh they're
basically all the same they're not all
the same some sheets are significantly
more comfortable than other sheets and
everything bull and branch makes is just
top-notch from bedding to blankets it's
made from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft and they
get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a hundred a thousand
dollars in the store well in branch
sheets are only a couple hundred bucks
everyone who tries bull and brand sheets
loves them that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company all are talking about bull and
branch even three u.s. presidents sleep
on bullet and branch sheets shipping is
free you can try them for 30 nights you
really have nothing to lose in if you
don't love them you send it back for a
refund but you're not gonna want to
because they really are that good my
wife and I have Bolin brand sheets we
sleep on them every night we got rid of
all of our other sheets because they are
spectacular to get you started right now
my listeners can get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bulla & branch
com promo code Ben that's bull and
branch comm today for 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets bol and branch comm
promo code Ben that's bull and branch
comm promo code been so quick note on
the undemocratic Senate thing so it's
mostly so I don't want to hit Aaron
black cause Aaron Blake is saying the
right thing there obviously but there
are a bunch of people on left like daily
coast guide David near and says please
stop lecturing us about how the Senate
is deliberately undemocratic by design
we know this we pointed out because we
think it's a bad thing except when you
thought it was a good
like two years ago right like when the
Democrats were intro in control of the
Senate like in 2014 2013 then you were
real happy with the Senate is
undemocratic it's it's like okay I love
this well lead shaheed who is a writer
for Cynthia Nixon he did comms and
policy for Cynthia Nixon he said the
Senate is undemocratic and it matters
Alec Alec McGillis is a reporter for Pro
Publica reporter saying the undemocratic
nature of representation in the Senate
is unlikely to be remedied any time soon
good job everybody okay so back to this
war on women narrative that that the
left is trotting out this is best
exemplified by a woman named Alexis
Grinnell she's written on gender and
politics for the New York Daily News The
Washington Post another outlet she's a
professional useless person and she
writes a piece today that has titled
white women come get your people they
will defend their privilege to the death
so what I like about this is that now
the left is not just attacking men now
it's not just a war on between women and
men
now it's a war between intersectionality
groups so it's black women versus white
women and Hispanic versus women versus
white women because it turns out white
women largely sided with Brett Kavanaugh
white women vote Republican more often
because it turns out a lot of women
actually think individually women don't
always think like the left wants them to
think which is fine and good I thought
the whole point of feminism is you get
to think what you want to think but not
according to the feminists here is this
insane P I mean this is fully crazy this
is like get the butterfly net and the
straightjacket stuff here is what here's
what Alexis Grinnell writes you know in
keeping with the the moderate tone of
the Democrats lately after a
confirmation process where women all but
slit their wrists letting their stories
of sexual trauma run like rivers of
blood through the Capitol the Senate
still voted to confirm judge Brett M
Kavanagh to the Supreme Court with the
exception of senator Lisa Murkowski of
Alaska all the women in the Republican
Conference caves including senator Susan
Collins of Maine who held out until the
bitter end all but slit their wrists
letting their stories of sexual trauma
run like rivers of blood through the
Capitol I wasn't aware that scream
people was a necessitating factor in
them agreeing with you and if you scream
at people about your experiences that
have nothing to do with Brett Kavanaugh
Brett Kavanaugh is guilty but Alexis
Cornell drops the hammer these women are
gender traders to borrow a term from the
dystopian TV series The Handmaid's Tale
first of all I think that we ought to
have a new rule now there's a rule on
the internet and about using Hitler I'm
trying to member the the rule about
using Hitler on the internet what's it
called
there there's an actual name for it that
they Godwin's law so it's called
Godwin's law that basically the longer
an Internet argument goes on the more
likely somebody is going to drop Hitler
in the middle of the argument well the
same thing now holds true for The
Handmaid's Tale call it Shapiro's law
the longer any argument goes on with the
left the the more of an opportunity the
left is going to have to drop a
reference to Handmaid's Tale the most
overrated book of last half-century and
a series that has become popular largely
because the media have decided that it
is deeply important for women to believe
that they are on the verge of being
sexually enslaved by men in a society
where fewer women than ever in American
history are getting married in which
women are waiting longer to get married
having fewer children and having a job
and having more more income from jobs in
than any time in American history but
women are this close they're this close
if Mike Pence has his way we're gonna
stick those women in those red burkas
and we're gonna just gonna send it and
we're gonna force them to reproduce with
us that's what we're gonna do if Mike
Pence has his way that evil evil Mike
Pence so here's what Alexis Cornell
writes these women are gender traitors
to borrow a term from the dystopian TV
series The Handmaid's Tale they've made
standing by the patriarchy a full-time
job the women who support them show up
at the Capitol wearing women for
Kavanagh t-shirts but also probably tell
their daughters to put on less revealing
clothes when they go out whoo they tell
their daughters not to dress all skimpy
whoo that means that they're bad mom's
the best moms tell their daughters to go
out in the streets naked that's the best
moms do I love that first of all I just
have to stop right there this notion
that if you tell your daughter not to
dress completely because she should
respect herself more than that that this
makes you a bad parent or restrictive
parents is utterly insane it's utterly
insane only
buddy who has never really raised
children in any serious capacity could
think this or maybe if you think there's
a like maybe have different strategy
maybe I don't know but about Alexis
Cornell situation maybe she has maybe
she has kids maybe maybe all I will say
is that it is a bad strategy to send
your teenage girl to a high school in
her bra and panties okay just gonna just
gonna say it's a bad idea and it doesn't
make you a bad parent to say so it means
they're trying to protect your daughter
from the fact that there are dangerous
people in the world and also because
maybe your daughter doesn't want to look
like a sex object all the time maybe she
does want to portray herself as a sex
object I like how the feminist movement
moved from the correct opinion about
pornography that pornography was
objectification of women for the
pleasure of men to pornography is
empowerment of women yeah I'm sure that
all those men who are in their basements
right now watching stormy Daniels old
tapes are thinking about the empowerment
of women they're all feminists that's
what they're thinking right now hey but
I love this women who show up at the
Capitol where and women for Kavanagh
t-shirts probably tell their daughters
to put on most revealing clothes as
though that as though say I also like
the equation put on less revealing
clothes is the same thing as we want to
make you a nun now okay when in modesty
becomes such a terrible thing I think
men should be modest too by the way
yeah just but let's not pretend that men
don't view women as sexualized objects
especially when women wear wear clothing
that makes them more likely to be viewed
as such it's a free country can wear
what you want I'm not saying you
shouldn't wear what you want I'm saying
I wouldn't I would tell my daughters
that because I'm not an idiot
okay here's that this piece continues
they're more sympathetic to senator
Orrin Hatch of Utah who actually shoot
away a crowd of women and told them to
grow up well right because they were
screaming at him like banshees we played
the tape on the show and then he told
them to grow up and then they told him
to grow up which was hilarious since
he's 1 million years old or Senator
Lindsey Graham of South Carolina whose
response to a woman telling him she was
raped was I'm sorry call the cops which
is again not an improper response like
I'm sorry that happened to you maybe you
should talk to the authorities so we can
catch the rapist and put him in jail is
not a horrible response I like that
that's it when did that become a bad
response like I'm just wondering what do
you think the Lindsey Graham's gonna do
you know grab his pistol like you
somebody Sam and you're gonna lead them
to a house he's going to burst through
the fun
or Lindsey Graham he's gonna burst
through the front door it's my quail
because I have to shoot this fella now
because this woman without any evidence
said that she was raped by you like that
that's gonna happen what do you think
Lindsey Graham is going to say you'd
want him to say yeah a woman comes up
says I was raped you think no you what's
he supposed to say at that point you
know what now that you told me you were
raped Brett Kavanaugh is a rapist what
in the okay this continues and we will
get deeper into the the insane maze-like
mind of the of the left on these on
these women's issues in just one second
but first first let's talk about how you
can keep your hair so you're looking up
top and you're figuring okay I'm losing
the hair up top and then you look your
pops and you say oh my dad lost all his
hair so maybe I should get active right
now in trying to stop all of that maybe
you've notice you have a little less
hair well the thing is there are two
clinically proven medications that let
you keep your hair and now they're
inexpensive and easy to get you don't
need to lose your hair if you don't want
to and that's why I have to tell you
about keeps for five minutes now just a
buck a day you're never gonna have to
worry about hair loss again a hair loss
runs in my family
and that's why I keeps works for me
getting started with keeps is really
easy sign up takes less than five
minutes just answer a few questions and
snap some photos a licensed doctor
remotely reviews your information
recommends the right treatment for you
all without ever leaving your couch
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda-approved hair loss products
out there something you probably tried
them before but you've never gotten them
this easily for this price keeps it's
only ten bucks to thirty five bucks a
month plus now you can get your first
month for free which is a heck of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair there's no
reason to put it off any longer
stop hair loss today the easy way with
keeps to receive that first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm
slash Ben that's ke EPS calm slash man
again free month of treatment at keeps
calm slash Ben keeps hair today
hair tomorrow ok so we are going to
discuss more of this plus I want to get
to an astronaut who apologized for
quoting Winston Churchill this is a
thing that actually happened in real
life we're gonna get to all of that well
have a quick couple notes on Columbus
Day as well coming up but first you're
gonna have to go over to daily wire and
subscribe so you can see the rest of the
show live for $9.99 a month you get the
rest of the show live the rest of
Michael moles a show live the rest of
Andrew Clavin show live and today daily
wire has launched the next chapter in
Andrew Clemens podcast series another
Kingdom performed by Michael Knowles
today
and on every following Monday
subscribers to the daily wire will be
able to watch new episodes of season two
if you're not a subscriber you won't be
able to watch those new episodes of
season two on Mondays you're gonna have
to wait until Fridays and you'll only be
able to see a few minutes of each
episode not the whole thing and this
season we've added a dramatic visual
component that you're not gonna want to
miss the artists really really cool
here's a clip from the first episode of
season two then finally it was dark time
to go with the locket still in my hand I
rolled off the bed there was nothing to
pack
I had nothing with me I ditched my phone
so no one could trace me I'd stopped at
an ATM near La to stock up on cash I
couldn't use credit cards they could
trace those two i dismantled the GPS in
my car no internet no social media I was
invisible and I was utterly alone I
crossed the brown carpet to the door I
opened the door onto the night outside
there was billiard ball he stood
gigantically on the threshold framed in
the doorway with the parking lot lights
glaring behind him before I could react
he jabbed me in the neck with a stun gun
the electric blast sent me reeling back
into the room convulsing down to the
floor
I dropped to the carpet jerking and
shuddering my muscles were locked up in
mobile all I could do was lie there and
judder and watch his billiard ball
stepped calmly into the room and calmly
shut the door behind him his enormous
shoulders were packed into a leather
jacket his muscles bulged through the
thin sweater he wore underneath he
looked down at my quivering body without
a smile without a sneer without any
emotion at all he hardly seemed
interested in what he saw he reached
into his jacket and slid the little stun
gun into his left inside pocket then he
reached across into his right inside
pocket and drew out a small leather case
terror exploded inside me as I watched
him unzip the case and deftly remove a
syringe I made a horrible helpless
gurgling noise in my throat as I battled
to get control of my body it was no use
my muscles had been severed from my will
well head on over to daily wire.com
subscribe to watch the first and second
seasons of another Kingdom sadly that
was not Michael Moses autobiography
because I'd love to hear about him being
tour
but nonetheless you can go check that
out right now for $99 a year you can get
the annual subscription that comes along
with our famous our world-famous leftist
tears hot or cold mug which has been our
tumbler which has been overflowing
continuously in fact TSA made us put it
aside because you're not allowed to
bring more than four ounces of liquid
through the TSA machines so when you
tried to bring it with us we had to
break we had to cloak it actually so I
have the cloaked version here with me
today go check that out right now over
at daily wire.com we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so the rampant mind loss that has taken
over large swaths of the left obviously
is is being forwarded by their belief
that if they just scream loud enough
about how men are sexist this will win
out Alexis Grinnell has this piece in
The New York Times we're going through
and I think it's indicative of a mindset
on the left that it's pretty insane so
here's that they've she's already
accused women who supported Brett
Kavanaugh or any Republican of being
traitors she says these are the kind of
women who think that being falsely
accused of rape is almost as bad as
being raped the kind of women who agree
with President Trump that it's a very
scary time for young men in America
which she said during a news conference
on Tuesday well it turns out you don't
actually to compare the two being
falsely accused of rape is pretty bad
being falsely accused of rape does
indeed ruin your life destroy your
reputation destroy your family I don't
have to compare that to rape because
there's no comparison like wow I don't
see the necessity of comparing the
crimes but being falsely accused of rape
is a kind of a bad thing and when
President Trump says it's a very scary
time for young men in America that is a
100% true I don't know a single mom not
a single mom with a boy who is not
worried about the possibility of where
all of this is going especially
considering the vagary of the nature of
consent in our current political
discourse we're now living in a time
when title mine charges can be brought
against basically any man on any campus
for any reason without any evidence and
destroy the guy's life
hey but here is here's Alexis Cornell
continuing the people who scare me the
most are the mother sisters and wives of
these young men because my stupid uterus
still holds out some insane hope of
solidarity first of all I just would
like to point out that this appeared in
the New York Times the most solid paper
in the United States according to folks
on the left and it printed a sentence in
which a woman said that her uterus holds
out hope ughter I do not hold out hope
uteri are an organ it's like me saying
my appendix holds out hope in case she
says we're talking about white women the
same 53 percent who put their racial
privilege ahead of their second-class
gender status in 2016 by voting to
uphold the system that values only their
whiteness just as they have for decades
so white women put their femininity
behind them they're not real women is
where this is going white women aren't
real women they're just white people
they're just faceless nameless white
people you
like these genderless widgets of
whiteness mmm
since 1952 white women have broken for
Democratic presidential candidates only
twice in the 1964 in 1996 elections
according to an analysis by Jane John a
political scientist at the University of
Southern California women of color and
specifically black women make the margin
of difference for Democrats the voting
patterns of white women and white men
mirror each other much more closely and
they tend to cast their ballots for
Republicans the gender gap in politics
is really a color line well actually
that's not really true the gender gap in
politics is really a marriage line if
you actually look at how single people
vote versus how married people vote
that's really the distinction married
people tend to vote heavily Republican
married women tends vote heavily
Republican single women tend to vote
heavily Democrat so it's not about color
and it's not about sex it's very much
about marital status why because when
you have kids and you start thinking to
the next generation when you start
thinking what's the kind of society
where I want to bring up a family and
when you start thinking you know I have
a family unit that requires protection
from an overarching federal government
that wants to get in my grill well that
changes your mind a little bit
but according to Alexis Cornell it's all
about the whiteness that's because white
women benefit from patriarchy by trading
on their whiteness to monopolize
resources for mutual gain in return
they're placed on a pedestal to be
cherished and revered as Speaker Paul
Ryan has said about women but all the
while denied basic rights this is just
nonsensical it's just nonsense if I even
know what that first sentence means
white women benefit from patriarchy by
trading on their whiteness to monopolize
resources for mutual gain first of all
replace white with black in that
sentence and obviously it's racist but
beyond that the idea that women are
somehow trading on their sexuality in
order to achieve some some decent
treatment at the hands of the patriarchy
this is all this is all crazy I'm sorry
this is all crazy stuff and if I urge
Democrats to run down this hill
screaming is like banshees as fast as
possible like please go do this make
this your electoral strategy all those
suburban white women who you're trying
to gain in the next election I urge you
to scream at them and tell them that
they're terrible people because they're
white go for that let's do that it's
it's amazing it's amazing so here here's
her evidence she says during the 2016
presidential elections in white women
really vote with their whiteness in mind
Laurie Fraser Jacque Lee a political
scientist at UCLA recently measured the
effect of racial identity on white
woman's willingness to support Trump in
2016 and found a positive and
statistically significant relationship
so white women who voted for him did so
to prop up their whiteness or
alternatively correlation does not equal
causation because that's basic
mathematical and statistical science
it's it's in the study white women who
agreed that many women interpret
innocent remarks or acts as sexist we're
17% more likely to vote for a Republican
candidate right that makes sense because
Democrats have gotten hysterical on this
issue and they have decided that
everything ought to be treated as rape
when Matt Damon suggested that Matt
Damon suggested there were gradations of
sexual misconduct he was run out of town
on a rail by folks on the Left so
finally she concludes this blood pact
between white men and white women is at
issue in the November midterms President
Trump knows it and at that Tuesday news
conference he signaled to white women to
hold the line the people that have been
complaining to me about it the most
about what's happening are women women
are very angry yes women are very angry
many mothers many mothers are very angry
and that crosses racial lines but this
is the the attempt militarized the me to
movement which was supposed to be a
bipartisan movement with basically
universal support no one wants to see
women mistreated has now been shattered
thanks to politics because the Left
decided that me too any allegation that
under me to any allegation brought
against someone they like is going to be
ignored and any allegation brought
against someone they don't like is going
to be upheld that's the way this now
works according to the left so me too
broke on the shoals of politics because
we were all on the same side with regard
to all of this stuff but no longer I
can't be on the same side as people who
want to do away with due process simply
because they think that this is somehow
going to enable women to vote for
Democrats not going to do that okay in
just a second I want to get to the
craziest story of the day the craziest
story of the day as it turns out is is
it comes courtesy of an astronaut and
this astronauts name is Scott Kelly so
Scott Kelly I know is here relation to
marquel Aziz I don't know any case
please a former astronaut he went into
space and I believe 1999 and he got
himself into hot water with the
political left why well not because
Scott Kelly's actually a right winger
he's not he actually tweeted this out
one of the greatest leaders of modern
times Winston Churchill said in victory
magnanimity
I guess those days are over now I could
argue with that tweet on the merits a
victory and magnanimity has not been
part of American politics for quite a
while I'm old enough to remember when
when Joe Biden told barack obama that
obamacare was a big effing deal i'm old
enough to remember when barack obama
shined a rainbow flag on the wall of the
White House after a bird fell I'm old
enough to remember after 2008 when
Barack Obama simply said to Republicans
I won and I have a memory I don't have
short-term memory loss and not Dory from
Finding Nemo like I remember all of this
stuff happening and but now we're told
that that it's bad if you celebrate
judge Cavanaugh being appointed to the
Supreme Court but here's the part that's
hilarious so Scott Kelley isn't ripped
up by the right for the sweet instead
he's ripped up by the left why because
he had the temerity to quote Winston
Churchill he tweeted out did not mean to
offend by quoting Churchill my apologies
I will go and educate myself further on
his atrocities racist views which I do
not support my point it was we need to
come together as one nation we are all
Americans that should transcend partisan
politics I will not come together with
anyone who says I cannot quote Winston
Churchill not going to happen I will not
come together with anyone who says I
cannot quote Abraham Lincoln because
Abraham Lincoln for most of his career
was a guy who believed in colonization
of black people in Africa from the
United States he was wrong about that
that was a bad perspective I am NOT
going to live in a country where I can't
quote Abraham Lincoln and suggest that
Abraham Lincoln was a he was not a hero
okay I'm not going to make common cause
of people who say that I cannot quote
Thomas Jefferson or George Washington or
the wide variety of historical figures
who were shaped by their time and held
opinions that are not within the
mainstream of today and are considered
immoral today you know why because
that's idiotic
there are two visions of Hal West words
vision one the West is based on certain
fundamental good principles and those
principles were held by people who
simultaneously did not live up to those
principles in the fullest way shaped as
they were by the times in which they
lived this is called being historically
accurate that there are lots of good
ideas embedded in times when lots of bad
things are happening
and this is the same thing that folks
say about that they very often used this
with regard to biblical criticism well
the Bible is an immoral document because
it contains things that we would not
like today so for example it talks about
slavery in the Bible that's like right
because the Bible was directed toward
people who were routinely enslaving
people and the Bible is attempting to
curb them from slavery which is why over
time the greatest advocates for freeing
slaves were actually biblically minded
people in the 18th and 19th centuries
the point is that either you see the
West as a repository of certain eternal
truths that we have not all lived up to
or you see it as a repository of evil
that must be torn down
and the same people who are saying you
can't quote Churchill are the people who
say we have to tear down the entire
structure from the inside it has to be
torn down root and branch and then when
we're finally done then we can erect a
new system in its place and so they'll
tell lies about Churchill right look
Churchill said some very nasty things
during his career things we would
consider nasty now right he heaped
racial scorn on a variety of groups
ranging from the Indians to the like
from India to the Sudanese to certain
Asian tribes but what the left has done
is they've taken those comments out of
context to suggest that he was in
complicit in genocide in Burma which is
not true to suggest that he wanted to to
gas people which is also not true he
wanted to he suggested using tear gas
against people to save their lives as
opposed to using bullets actually and
and you know the so they take all the
stuff out of context this has relevance
today not only because it demonstrates
the extremism of the left that we're now
at the point where you're not allowed to
quote Winston Churchill but it explains
why there's this big fight that's now
taking place over Columbus Day so on the
left the perspective is that Columbus
Day is bad because Western civilization
is bad and so we must celebrate
indigenous peoples day on the day that
Columbus discovered Hispaniola and on
the right the perspective is Christopher
Columbus and the West have committed a
lot of sins but it is an eminently good
thing for the world that Western
civilization found the Western
Hemisphere that's the basic argument
it's really not about Columbus it's
about the value of Western civilization
that's really at root that is what the
argument is about ok so meanwhile I want
to talk about some things that I like
and then we'll talk about some things
that I hate so things that I like today
Heather McDonald has a fantastic
fantastic piece over at city journal in
which she talks about the moving
definition of Ray
it's called trauma and truth the
feminist movement has shifted the
definition of rape to include regret and
she talks specifically about it's very
difficult to come to agreement on me to
when you won't define your terms so what
she says when she points out is that
impress here's what she says she does in
preparation for the next Salem witch
trial like ordeal therefore is worth
empirically rebutting the believe
survivors mandate as well as its
corollary the claim that if most self
professed rape survivors in our
patriarchal culture don't report their
assaults that's because the social and
emotional costs are too high as
california congressman ted Lieu explain
on msai MSNBC last sunday and the point
that heather mcdonald makes is that a
lot of a lot of the variability in how
sexual activity takes place makes for
confusion about what exactly rape is and
so when the left has draws this hard
line where anything woman says rape is
is rape what they are really doing is
they're refusing to acknowledge the
inherent vagaries of sexual
relationships say here's what Heather
McDonald says and this is this is
correct in 2015 the Association of
American Universities conducted a sexual
assault survey at 27 selective colleges
the vast majority of survey respondents
whom the AAU researchers classified as
sexual assault victims never reported
their alleged assaults their colleges
rape hotline sexual assault Resources
centers or title nine offices much less
to campus or City police and the
overwhelming reason the alleged victims
did not report is that they did not
think that what happened to them was
that serious at Harvard for example over
69% of female respondents who check the
box for penetration by use of force did
not report the incident to any authority
most of those non reporters 65% did not
think that their experience was serious
enough to report now why is that that's
because in college campuses we have what
is called the yes means yes standard
which means that if a woman goes through
with the act of sex with a guy and
they're both drunk and she wakes up the
next morning and she didn't say yes at
every step because she was drunk then
therefore she was raped but in many
cases the woman says you know what I
wasn't really raped
I made her I made a report I didn't feel
it was that serious
now is she wrong is her subjective
opinion wrong or is it possible that
people are subjective in their opinions
of what constitutes consent like there's
certain hard lines that we all agree to
write forcible rape is rape and then
there's a bunch of
gray area and failing to acknowledge the
gray area with regard to this stuff
leads to absurdities like the yes means
yes rules no one has ever had sex with a
legal checklist on hand no one in
history has ever done this and so when
people on college campuses say you're
supposed to say like can I touch your
hand now can I touch your shoulder now
can I touch your knee now there's a
great episode of new girl where I'm
where what's the name of the star of new
girl I'm trying to member her name you
know the bangs there's gonna drive me
crazy in any case she her character
whose main character in is Thank You
Zoey additionnal her character is is
going out with a high school boyfriend
it's prom night and she wants to have
sex with him and he sits down with her
knees a feminist and so he goes to I
permission to touch her hand she's like
yes and he has he's like I permission to
touch her names like yes and finally
after his final she's like listen you
have permission to do anything you want
your permission to do whatever you want
and he's like but I don't feel
comfortable with that he said I feel
like you're getting aggressive with me
now and so she ends up running out and
having sex like some random guy behind
like in the in the children's play area
right like that's it because no one
actually operates like this okay no one
operates like this and that's not to
suggest that bad things don't happen
women terrible things happen to women
all the time
that's true but we actually have to
define our terms if you want all of us
to agree on things I want to agree with
these women
I want to believe victims I want to
believe survivors I want to but I have
to know what definitions were using and
I have to know what the corroborate of
evidence is otherwise we have just a
moving standard a moving target like a
good example you remember when the
entire left went nuts over Aziz Ansari
inviting a woman back to his apartment
whom he had sex with and then she was
like oh yeah I was raped and you read
her story and there was nothing in there
that suggested she was sexually
assaulted or raped nothing and they went
nuts over it anyway and you had to
apologize and do I think that this has
become a moral panic yes I think this
has become a moral panic heaven
McDonald's piece is really good she says
our booze-fueled hookup culture has made
relations between men and women messier
than ever leaving many girls and women
with pangs of regret but those regrets
do not equal rape if we were actually in
the midst of an epidemic of sexual
assault as New Jersey senator Cory
Booker asserted the evening of the Ford
Kavanagh hearings we would presumably
have seen women and girls take
protective actions such as avoiding frat
parties and flocking to singles
schools none of those protective actions
has occurred however either women are
too clueless to avoid patent danger or
the epidemic of sexual assault is a
fiction all evidence points to the
latter consideration it's a good piece
by Heather McDonald and she is in large
part correct okay other things that I
like so I have to give props to Banksy
not a big fan of Banksy's art but I will
say that this was an amazing amazing
prank so Banksy but created a painting
of a girl with the balloon and sold it
at a Sotheby's auction it went for I
think 1.4 million dollars and he had his
art rigged so that when the final gavel
was sounded the painting would begin to
shred itself it would go through the
bottom the sore the bottom barrier of
the of the frame and actually physically
shred which is hilarious because the
truth is that the value of art is
entirely subjective it's entirely
subjective and it's based on artificial
scarcity and he's making that point so I
have to I have to give it to me I think
there's a pretty good prank and he'll
sell the thing for more money after it's
been half shredded because now he made a
meta point because this is what art is
it's not really appreciation of the
artists appreciation of the meta point
of the message so I think banks he may
not even understand the the amount to
which he's mocking the art community I
think he thinks he's mocking capitalism
but he's actually mocking the
subjectivity of art but nonetheless is
pretty funny here's some video
and then look to the wall oh there goes
the painting and the sight and the
audience goes silent and shocked oh my
god what just happened people can't
believe it
so that's pretty funny so good times
alright time for a couple of things at
that I hate okay so Pete Davidson was on
SNL over the weekend SNL has just been
agreed just this season because folks on
the Left are utterly incapable of making
light of the events happening there it's
for folks on the left the feeling that
they have down in the pit of their
stomachs is that their brother just died
and because their brother just died how
can you joke about your brother just
dying
so instead you just get kind of bitter
and cynical and nasty and that's
basically what you're seeing from SNL
these days so Pete Davidson did a
Weekend Update on SNL apparently wearing
one of Hillary Clinton's like long
sleeve t-shirts I mean he's like wearing
an attainder you know he's wearing it's
like a tangerine orange kind of
long-sleeve t-shirt it looks like he was
picking up stuff on the side of the road
before he came in any case he goes off
on kanye west why because Kanye West was
on SNL the previous week and and warn
his Maggie hat and then talked about how
people weren't tolerant of opposing
viewpoints so Pete Davidson decides that
he's going to show his tolerance of
opposing viewpoints by telling Kanye to
as the left might say shut up and
dribble speaking strictly for myself
what Kanye said after we went off the
air last week was one of the worst like
most awkward things I've ever seen here
and I've seen Chevy Chase speak to an
intern and we all had to stand behind
him and here's what it looked like so I
I'm like on the left oh my god
like I want a career so I leave being
mentally ill is not an excuse to act
like a jackass and then he went on to
say that Connie is a genius at art but
he doesn't know anything about politics
you're a comedian nude like you're on
SNL and yet you know something about
politics I'm old enough to remember I
keep using that phrase today because the
hypocrisy the left is so strong I'm old
enough to remember when Laura Ingram was
ripped up and down for suggesting that
LeBron James should shut up and dribble
because he knew basketball but that
didn't mean he knew politics and I said
at the time anybody's entitled to their
opinion on politics but we get to assess
whether those opinions are smart or not
Kanye is entitled to his opinion on
politics and listen this is coming from
the guy who said live by the Kanye die
by the Kanye but when folks on the Left
suddenly discover that Kanye West is a
celebrity and maybe celebrities don't
have the smartest takes on politics it's
kind of ironic and kind of silly okay
other things that I hate so cnn's
original headline on this story was just
terrible the original headline was
Israelis report that Palestinian kills
two Israelis in terror attack wasn't
that a Palestinian killed two people in
terror attack their original report
suggested that it was a workplace
violence incident which is absurd what
actually happened is that over the
weekend a 27 year old Israeli named Kim
Yehezkel was tied up an executed
point-blank by a Palestinian co-worker
in the West Bank
a place where Jews and Arabs work
together the Palestinian Authority
obviously will give money to the
terrorist family she leaves behind a
baby daughter and a husband she was one
of two people who was killed as a
picture of her obviously a very
beautiful young woman and she was
murdered for the crime of being a Jew
and living in Judea and Samaria that's
exactly what happened here the media
covered it as they always do as the
predictable effect of an occupation
which is pretty astonishing that if you
are working at a factory next to Arabs
with whom you share a life and one of
them murders you that this is because of
your religion specifically because of
your religion then it must be because of
global factors there can't be personal
responsibility on any level here we have
to assume that people don't have freedom
of action okay so that's a great tragedy
I believe there's a GoFundMe
the family I'll try and tweet it out a
little bit later if I can find him okay
let's do a quick Federalist paper since
we've been remiss the last few weeks so
we are all the way up to Federalist 46
in this Federalist paper Madison is
wrong so here is where Madison is wrong
James Madison argues in favor of the
notion that the people will be more
loyal to the states than they are to the
federal government so this is still true
in like Texas and not true pretty much
anywhere else I live in California no
one is more loyal to the state of
California than they are to the federal
government no one it's just not the way
it works no one says I'm a Californian
that's that's not how it operates but
Madison says truth in the less than
decency requires that the event in every
case should be supposed to depend on the
sentiments and sanction of their common
constituents many considerations besides
those suggested on a former occasion
seem to place it beyond doubt that the
first and most natural attachment of the
people will be to the governments of
their respective states and originally
of course this was true at the time of
the founding people were more loyal to
the state of Virginia than they were to
the federal government which is why note
to leftists the Senate requires two
votes per state because the only way the
states were going to sign on is if they
felt that they had enough insurance
against the popular vote that they could
afford to sign on to a federal
constitution smaller states didn't want
their authority withdrawn from them
without their permission not on the
basis of having a smaller population
that's why there is a United States
Senate today
Madison argues the only way the federal
government could ever earn the
appreciation of the people would be
terrific administration he says if the
people should in the future become more
partial to the federal than the state
government the change would only result
from manifest and irresistible proofs of
a better administration that obviously
is untrue he missed the the point which
that if the federal government grows and
grows and grows and encroaches and
encroaches and encroaches slowly and
more slowly then people would just get
used like like a lobster and pot they
just get used to the heat they just get
used to the federal government being
deeply important in their lives and then
he adds that the federal government
would seriously take into account state
interests just the state legislators
take into account county interests but
he says in the end and this is the point
that the left really doesn't want to
acknowledge because it ties into second
Amendment rights he says that the states
if the federal government got too big
for its britches the states would would
cut it down to size he says that is
quietude of the people they're repugnant
and perhaps refusal to cooperate with
the officers of the Union the frowns of
the executive man
three of the state the embarrassments
created by legislative devices which
would often be added on such occasions
would oppose in any state difficulties
not to be despised would form in a large
state very serious impediments and where
the sentiments of several adjoining
states happen to be in unison would
present obstructions the federal
government would hardly be willing to
encounter in other words if you start
encroaching on states rights the states
will fight back against you and they
will stop you from such encroachments
this is the reason why people in Texas
don't want to give up their guns to the
federal government because they believe
that Figg up your guns you're giving up
all your other rights as well he says
the only real problem would be federal
power for its own sake and he says that
would never happen because the state
governments with the people on their
side would be able to repel the danger
so Madison was pretty clear about what
the function of States and arms
ownership was in Federalist 46 okay well
we will be back here tomorrow with all
the latest tonight we're at University
of Buffalo so go check us out at yah org
slash live to watch them be going off on
radical feminism that is the topic of
tonight's speech all new material so it
should be a lot of fun we'll see you
then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018